das geht aber netz bekommen haben ein
video ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
alter wir haben hier in meiner heimat
heute 33 grad in berlin sind es einfach
37 grad ich fahre ich jetzt gleich nach
berlin dort steht eine premiere an und
ich dachte mir ich muss die chance auf
jeden fall auch nutzen um mal wieder ein
bisschen essen zu testen ich habe auf
jeden fall berger auf meinem plan aber
auch was anderes ich hoffe ich schaffe
das alles weil ich habe auch relativ
viel zu tun in berlin aber wenn da ganz
optimistisch und ich würde sagen wir
starten jetzt erst mal nach bielefeld
zum hauptbahnhof dann fahre ich mit dem
zweiten mal wieder mit dem zug nach
berlin viel spaß zum video leute keine
ahnung was das am ende wird aber auch
zum bahnhof so leute für mich geht es
mit dem zug von bielefeld hauptbahnhof
city west nach berlin und damit mich die
ganzen schreienden kinder im zug mich
nerven habe ich hier die neuen sound cox
45 ihre kopfhörer dabei und ich denke
die werden wir gut dabei helfen und noch
ein bisschen flippige musik auf das ist
nice
leute ich hab freundlicherweise von
sound core die neuen space kuh 45
kopfhörer zugeschickt bekommen das ganze
interview kopfhörer kommen einem super
schicken design wie man hier sehen kann
perfekt für reisen im flugzeug wenn ihr
einfach ihre ruhe haben wollt denn die
dinger haben noise cancelling und die
reduzieren störende geräusche um bis zu
98 prozent innovative technik sorgt für
eine höhere klangqualität eine höhere
akustik das habe ich auch save bei
dieser reise gemerkt ich extra lange
batterielaufzeiten könnt ihr auch ohne
probleme von deutschland nach amerika
jetten und habt ein super entspanne
sounderlebnis der tragekomfort ist
natürlich auch gegeben wie man hier
sieht ich habe die kuh 45 hat bei uns
jetzt in schwarz gewählt es gibt auch
alternative farben wie weiß oder blau
und ich muss sagen die kuh 45 hat von
haben mich auf jeden fall überzeugt ihr
könnt euch außerdem auch die neue
soundtrack app runterladen und dort eure
sound kopfhörer mit verknüpfen dann noch
ein paar features einstellen ich bin
ohne schreiende kinder in berlin
angekommen und wir schauen jetzt mal was
ich da so erlebt habt gestern war
hausparty premiere wo ich mitgespielt
habe so ein format wo man was trinken
musste und dann mussten wir noch mehr
trinken und wer dann am meisten
getrunken hat und am besten sich mit
allen anderen verstanden hat hat es
schon am ende gewonnen und alle anderen
sind dann mit der zeit immer
rausgeflogen hat auf jeden fall spaß
gemacht und da war gestern die premiere
deswegen bin ich in berlin und ich
dachte mir eigentlich wollte ich hier
zwei neiße essens videos drehen zum
einen wie in jeder stadt die drei besten
burger restaurants gestern habe ich dann
angefangen hier vielleicht mal ein ganz
kurzer ausschnitt spielleute ich befinde
mich gerade auf dem weg zur
bürgermeister habe ich zwar schon ultra
ob getestet aber dann lief vom
hauptkanal oder vorne ist ja leider
schon wir sehen irgendwie alle gleich
aus mittlerweile ja es gibt mittlerweile
schon sieben leben von bürgermeister in
berlin als ich die zum erster probiert
habe gab es zwei und die sind in so
alten toiletten längst euch hier mal ein
[Musik]
so leute bürgermeister burger ist geholt
ich muss sagen die dinger sind wirklich
preiswert aber echt unfassbar
lagerfläche cheeseburger kostet gerade
mal 58 höher als zum ersten mal gestern
waren sogar noch 54 also wirklich da
kann man absolut nicht mehr kannst so
leute ich bin wieder zurück im hotel und
wir machen jetzt erstmal ein
kameraobjektiv schutz aber das war dumm
und jetzt haben wir einmal die com ist
auch die ich teilweise schon mal ein
bisschen mein und ein bisschen ketchup
drauf gemacht habe ist nämlich dann
gratis man mayo und ketchup widmen
möchte kostet 50 cent pro packung ganz
schön teuer
wirklich so lacker und hierbei stieß
bürgern aber ich muss sagen die
bürgermeister von müssen jetzt nicht so
heftig also wir sind auch nicht verkehrt
jetzt zum besseren funktionieren
wird teurer also der sieht weg ich schon
los aus das hier ist bestimmt schon so
meine fünfzehnter bürgermeister burger
und ich bin mal gespannt was für eine
benotung dieses prachtexemplar heute von
mir bekommt
also bei bürgermeister ist ja so die
session das fleisch auf es sind so
gesehen smash burger eigentlich neues
modell schon sehr krass wäscht oder das
fleisch ist extrem stark angebrachten
also es ist sehr kostet man drauf weist
und irgendwie geht so dadurch ein
bisschen der geschmack verloren
bisschen schade weil ich habe auf jeden
fall von deutlich bessere
bürgermeisterwahl in frankfurt es ist
trotzdem solide bürger aber um hand tut
er mich wollte eine recht ist ein
bisschen schade ihr fehlt auf jeden fall
einiges wobei schon bist du bist besser
wird mit 7,8 und zehn punkte aber ich
hatte eigentlich damit gerechnet dass
ich den heutigen neuen geben muss leider
nicht noch einige dazukommen ist mit ein
bisschen was
genau war ich muss sagen ich hab leider
einen wichtigen termin rein bekommen den
ich heute wahrnehmen muss und deswegen
kann ich dieses pack burger wie wir zu
ende drehen weil ich morgen früh schon
wieder nach hause muss aber das wäre auf
jeden fall tun wenn ich das nächste mal
hier bin und ich dachte mir trotzdem wir
machen jetzt noch ein paar und zwar
wollte ich immer schon mal inhalt
deutschen großstadt deutsches essen
bestellen berlin ist so multikulti und
ja hier gibt es natürlich auch deutsche
restaurants und eins ist mir aufgefallen
man kann tatsächlich in berlin ein
originales wiener schnitzel mit zwölf
euro 80 bestellen und das wollte ich
einfach mal ausprobieren dann testen
auch noch eine currywurst hier weil die
habe ich auch noch nie probiert gucken
mal macht bin jetzt hier gerade auf
meiner lieblings apps von bin hier im
hotel in berlin das ist direkt über
einem exit also man fährt hier hoch oder
kommt zuerst in der kid und darüber ist
ein hotel direkt am kudamm und jetzt
zeige ich euch mal hier deutsches essen
zack zack und dann habe ich eben
gefunden genau restaurant maria ist
komisch die haben nämlich noch gar keine
bewertung aber hier gibt es tatsächlich
das originale wiener schnitzel vom kalb
12 eur 80 was unfassbar günstiges also
ich weiß nicht warum gegen die macht mir
das auch ein bisschen sorge weil ich es
eigentlich nur wirklich qualitativ
hochwertiges fleisch wenn ich vielleicht
versuche ich halt wirklich drauf zu
achten und 12 euro 80 irgendwie
runtergesetzt von 16 euro ist natürlich
super günstig und lässt darauf schließen
dass ist wally partie vielleicht nicht
der oberstadt ist aber wer weiß wo ich
hätte das gerne an statt mit guten salat
mit pommes und preiselbeeren sind auch
dabei das ist nämlich super wichtig weil
ohne preise werden ist ein wiener
schnitzel ich ein originales wiener
schnitzel bin gespannt und ich würde
sagen ich bestelle das mal und mal
gucken was da an kommt dass ich auf
jeden fall das günstigste wiener
schnitzel was ich je gegessen haben als
zweites bestelle ich dann jetzt hier auf
bei west curry curry würstchen ein
bisschen sind in berlin ja auch so dass
dinge und es gibt super viele currywurst
buden und da dachte ich mir currywurst
mit new classic ist nicht verkehrt 11
eur 50 laden hat auf jeden fall super
bewertungen und werde dann zutaten sind
ja ich finde das gut und berlin style
klassische currywurst mit semmel schön
unscharf und ketchup und coca cola
dann bestellen wir das auch noch und
dann haben wir zwei sachen die wir
testen können hier aus berlin ziehen und
beim nächsten mal verspricht ich
bestelle ich auch mal wieder das
schlechteste deutsche essen oder das
schlechteste essen generell darauf hatte
ich heute wirklich überhaupt keinen bock
das ist essen ist das eingetroffen wir
haben hier über ex die currywurst für 11
eur 50 mit ketchup also berufs technisch
auf jeden fall erstmal nicht verkehrt
meine zimmer karte bei auch drin ist
verständlich dar weil ich eben
auszusehen reingeschmissen hat
eigentlich habe ich dazu geschrieben
habe shrek ist ja beide haben hier zwei
so pixar und wir haben auch noch brot
das ist auch wichtig zu einer currywurst
also ich kenne curry würstchen
eigentlich nur somit um dicken
fleischigen weissbrodt haben wir die
pommes frites und hier dann
wahrscheinlich die curry wo es bleibt
hier das ist ja eine kleine portion
currywurst mit röstzwiebeln netapp hat
60 cent extra gekostet bisschen teuer
aber gut probieren wir erstmal ne pommes
davide kommissar und breit war auch noch
dabei das habe ich ja ganz vergessen die
muss ich jetzt auch nicht trinken wasser
ist gesünder steht mir immer was sein
wenn ich mal gespannt auf die currywurst
brennt ja okay ich weiß eigentlich sind
die originale curry würstchen auch vom
schwein aber ich es kein schwein wetters
zwiebeln dran das sieht schon der chaos
also leute guten hunger
auf jeden fall eine gute mannschaft
herbert scharf gewesen am
donnerstag wird immer schärfer doch alle
noch
also ich muss sagen wirklich eine der
besten currywürste nicht ganz ein
bisschen wirklich einen der besten chöre
wurst würfe die ich je in meinem leben
gegessen habe da man sich auf jeden fall
können hier von curry deluxe wie normal
aber leute jetzt gleich kommt auch mein
schnitzel an und darauf bin ich mal sehr
gespannt so leute hier haben wir das
schnitzel eigentlich ist es interessant
dabei guck mal ich hab das ganze
überhaupt nichts bestellt aber es ist
nicht in not that much mpg koptische
food delivery partner gegen eine ahnung
was das ist dann haben wir dazu reise
werde jetzt vermutlich das schnitzel
rind hat extra besteck dazu angefordert
aber kein besteck erhalten was machen
wir jetzt ich bin halt im hotel also mal
gucken was haben wir denn hier drin
jetzt liegen also brot
da gibt's dann zu einem wiener schnitzel
brot dazu aber okay vielleicht einfach
nett so warum nicht ich mich auch gar
nicht beschweren und jetzt gucken wir
mal hier hat man leute kleine beauty
sets einwendungen hier für euch es sieht
soweit wirklich stabil aus ich bin immer
ein freund davon wenn das schnitzel so
dünn ist wie möglich ja okay also die
panade könnte noch ein bisschen
kräftiger sein aber ich will mich gar
nicht beschweren also ich hab wirklich
damals in köln als ich auch mal
deutsches essen bestellt habe schon viel
schlimmere schnitzel gesehen das macht
auf mich erstmal soliden eindruck und
auch die pommes den einstands gut aus
ein bisschen preise werden also meiner
meinung nach die person die gesagt hat
preise werden gehören dazu hätte eine
auszeichnung verdient weil das ist
einfach so war er ich liebe preise
werden zu einem schnitzel und wenn es
dann noch ein gutes schnitzel es was
vielleicht sogar nur 12 euro 80 gekostet
hat auf jeden fall nicht verkehrt wie
müssen wir das ganze ohne besteck ganz
abreißen ja gut warum nicht mehr gott
mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen dass
mich das überzeugen wird für den preis
aber man schmeckt ja auch wenn die
qualität stimmt
ich fühle mich hier richtig wir sollen
frühzeitig also einen noch aber ich muss
leider sagen dass total versalzen also
der erste geschmackstest war in ordnung
dann kam so ein komischer nachgeschmack
die panade irgendwie versetzen und es
schmeckt ein bisschen komisch ist
natürlich schade weil ich finde auch
wiener schnitzel ist ein gericht was man
durchaus bestellen kann per lieferung
zumindest wenn es eine gute qualität hat
macht bei mir auf dem dorf machen aber
dieses fingerschnipp hat leider nicht so
viel zu tun mit einem guten wiener
schnitzel und ich könnte diesem wiener
schnitzel auch maximal war hier von zehn
punkten geben und ich würde mich jetzt
mal auch nicht so weit aus dem fenster
lehnen wenn ihr das hier sehr um zu
sagen dass die qualität von fleisch
keine gute ist leider und das tut mir
auch irgendwie leid weil das ist halt
extrem wichtig klar da hätte ich mal
darauf hören sollen dass sie noch keine
bewertungen haben bin ich jetzt der
erste der die bewertet weil ich muss
sagen ich hab das restaurant auch so
gejubelt und die haben hier drei sterne
bei google was ja in ordnung ist und bei
coop city wahrscheinlich neu aber das
ist wirklich leider kein gutes wiener
schnitzel leute ich weiß das war jetzt
kein mega bio trotzdem habe ich einen
wiener schlüssels für 12 euro 80 in
berlin bestellt das wahrscheinlich auch
noch nicht so viele danke fürs zuschauen
und wir sehen uns dann nicht da gibt's
hier